we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
continued confusion folks
am I a socialist or not I am not a
socialist but the confusion continues
hi David this is lokesh from Atlanta
Georgia well I want to ask you
last couple years ago and I wanted to
ask what label best describes your
politics now in 2022 thanks have a nice
day bye-bye okay it's actually 2023 with
all due respect I know we're all making
that same mistake it's I'm still doing
the yeah anyway
um I this might come as a shock I am
still a Social Democrat social democracy
being a well-regulated form of
capitalism I am still there
and uh
yeah I don't the confusion about my
politics has certainly increased lately
but I am still not a socialist and I
know there are people waiting anxiously
for that to happen but for the time
being I am still a Social Democrat we
have a great bonus show for you today
Texas has a bill which would ban nearly
all gender affirming care including for
transgender adults adults who are
supposedly able to make the decisions
that they believe are best for them
lawyers for Donald Trump propaganda
Steve Bannon are now suing Bannon over
legal bills
Apple doesn't fall far from the tree
does it and a Florida lawyer argues that
a pregnant inmate's fetus is being
illegally detained this actually could
be a really big deal case all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad no comment on
that but I do invite you to join us on
the bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com